hello and welcome to this video shushing
hi wa8 played him often but not so much
recently the prairie recall what kind of
openings we had on the bond if we play
this don't know there is a good player
I've got a minus one score over more
than 20 games
now White has a couple of moves here B
should be 2 9 f3 and they sell
on extremely complicated we should be to
now is normal now I'm quite sure anymore
how it continues
I'm not really sure how to play I'm
usually trying to put pressure on d5 in
this position but I'm unsure about them
the move orders 90 for coming
194 I would probably like to play Bishop
a6 on Knight b6 I know it's got 95 mm
and I have played that too quickly
okay um so maybe it isn't that bad sighs
- lets not be Phi was ah
I was stupid with my BDSM oh yeah it's
good 95 I can actually play with d7
against that room okay it was not
intended might work
[Music]
yeah I saw that
but I couldn't quite figure out why that
would make anything or that would do
anything you know I think I just take it
96 Queen b6 what's the problem I don't
see it why it's White's Knights look
like they somehow have lost their way
now this has no square can you play I'm
totally sure Bev three on something
weird time I shouldn't work now that I
can take of course
um can I do anything better probably not
so this should be seven doesn't work
right actually does look let's do it
then it's easiest yeah I don't want to
try to hook I think that Lukas doing a
good job on the dog on those open files
what I need is good positions for my
nights one night night could come to d4y
and this pollution that would be good
and they have to open up the diagonal I
mean I will probably open on time so try
to find good moves this looks good
so I wonder I see 493 and that looks
fine it's a huge hole now 93 okay now
should use this night like preparing 95
to before again
I take a seven look chicks can see why
we should be 5 chick it's not a slowly
clean win and ok girl
Arthur no so much let's think about it
for a moment
[Music]
I probably just this one check
play resides towers stranger all of a
sudden his nights hypnose squares and I
don't know probably our killer engine
actually I I think my position is okay
yeah off the 97 I couldn't couldn't
quite quite remember yeah this is
sisters and just doesn't do all that
much and that doesn't work it just
doesn't work here the Knights have no
squares now my black wings you probably
should just take on v6 and TM
I mean I have some compensation maybe
not enough I think I asked you to move
up somehow don't quite remember we need
to look it up on what I actually do here
look a to e7 edit it is interesting
address counter-attacking here it's a
much much sharper way of doing it and
turn yeah yeah and it likes the small
that was probably the better choice okay
guys thanks for watching